foreign
[Music]
I'm an associate professor of aerospace
engineering and Engineering mechanics at
the University of Texas at Austin I'm
also an affiliate researcher with space
enabled at the media lab and I'm an MLK
visiting professor
and result a very satellite that we put
up there is to One Day become a piece of
garbage
if it's large enough parts of it will
survive re-entry and then hit some
portion of the planet
because the planet is mostly covered by
water
chances are to land in the ocean
when you start seeing School Bus size
objects eventually it's going to land on
a populated area and people will die as
a consequence of a school bus size
object re-entering when that could have
been avoided and so the way that we've
treated our ocean assuming oh the
ocean's big who cares we're doing that
to space and I'm here to say look the
oceans in the land can teach us we don't
have to repeat the same kind of mistakes
we track over 40 000 human-made objects
in Earth orbit ranging in size from a
cell phone all the way to the space
station
these robots in the sky that we call
Satellites that provide a lot of data
and information that helps Humanity
understand itself more than by any other
means Earth observation climate change
war in Ukraine Communications internet
position navigation timing all of these
are space-based infrastructures that are
not protected or shielded from the
likelihood that some piece of junk going
at 15 times speed of a bullet
crashes against it and then obliterates
it right now on average we're launching
over 12 satellites per week
just like we're trying to minimize
single-use Plastics we should try to
minimize single-use satellites and make
them reusable and recyclable
high-tech and deep Tech have outpaced
ancient Tech
meaning we're not having a successful
conversation with the environment the
unintended consequences of our behaviors
are leading us to Extinction
and so can humanity take the foot off
the gas pedal allow mother nature to
provide feedback to us about the
unintended consequences of our behaviors
and then from there can we make some
informed decisions based on Ancient Tech
and leveraging the high-tech to make the
ancient Tech scale
[Music]